people love to complain sometimes their
grapes are founded in sometimes they're
not
regardless you can't deny that thanks to
web sites like Reddit Twitter YouTube
and Facebook the casual fan is far far
more knowledgeable about what they are
viewing these days
be it scripts pacing animation or the
misuse of characters if one hiccup is
noticed by one individual
you better believe shockwaves will be
felt throughout the entire community so
what happens when you drag an eighties
anime kicking and screaming and plop it
down into the modern era
well inconsistencies potholes and just
general carelessness ensues
so I figured that it's time to channel
my inner rage monkey and count down the
top ten times Dragon Ball super made us
fans rage number 10 chugga-chugga let it
be known I don't agree with every entry
on this list this is one of those
instances but I can see where the
outrage is coming from in some respect
to understand this would must first
understand who oughta magetta
is as a character introduced in episode
32 of Dragon Ball super ultimate geta is
explained to be a member of a race of
metal men not robots Metal Men and
that's important the vocalizations while
annoying were created by a person and
the sounds like a person in some way
this frees up the voice actor playing
the role of McKenna to convey emotions
effectively this is very important as
his means of defeat in episode 36 the
hands of Vegeta comes from his inability
to take insults well which results in
now this is where the fan outrage comes
in on September 30th 2017 the English
dub revealed what they thought magetta
should sound like
remember emotions are important for this
character to convey and he is not a
robot okay he's not a robot this is what
they went with
that sure sounds like a not robot to me
as you can see attributes that make up
the character magetta were altered and
warped affecting his character's
motivation and weaknesses thus leading
to fans being upset with the direction
of the character despite a period
literally a handful of episodes in the
entire series making it practically
irrelevant next number 9 devaluing super
saiyan this one I think has legs if you
were to ask any person who watched
Dragonball Z back in the day to recall a
specific moment or instance nine times
out of ten they'll mention a Super
Saiyan transformation of some
description this is because once the
series reached the climax of the Frieza
fight with Goku Akira Toriyama made damn
sure everyone knew how badass awesome
and most importantly how difficult it
was to earn that Super Saiyan state
it was a story thoughts will be to miss
almost lost to time entirely no one had
achieved the legendary Super Saiyan form
in over a thousand years it took Goku a
Saiyan raised under extremely unusual
circumstances placed in the situation he
needed to survive and protect his loved
ones against the then overlord of the
universe Frieza everyone remembers that
scene and everyone remembers how it
began with the death of Goku's longtime
friend Crillon to go on Vegeta trunks
all had meaningful first time
transformations
except for Goten in them [ __ ] 10 sucks
anyway kale and cauliflower are
introduced late into Dragon Ball super
because Koba had been established as
being the first Saiyan to achieve the
state naturally cauliflower kale have no
idea what the transformation is either
this leads to an awkward collection of
scenes where acaba describes the Super
Saiyan transformation as anti [ __ ] you
not a tingling sensation in your back a
legendary transformation thought to be
unattainable by an entire race of beings
has been reduced to a tingling sensation
in your back oh and look it worked
needless to say this rub fans the wrong
way right off the bat it's awesome that
we get some female Super Saiyans but
honestly I would have liked if some
effort had been put into their training
scenes right now cauliflower and kale
are suffering from what I call DC
syndrome Goku and Vegeta are marvel they
got their first established and earned
their powers while the fans watched
Khalifa and Kayla on the other hand are
trying to catch up as fast as possible
to join in on the fun and unfortunately
that kind of
sucks number eight the misuse of frost
and piccolo we all love a good villain
but we also love a good swerve on
February 21st 2016 episode 32 of Dragon
Ball super aired and with it came the
unveiling of a new character going by
the name of frost longtime fans of the
series immediately saw striking
similarities between frost and a former
villain Frieza to the surprise of most
frost introduced himself and by all
accounts during his match with Goku was
a likeable character with a fun
backstory it very easily could have been
a situation where frost became a
discount Frieza but by the time episode
34 rolled around frost had assembled
quite the following online thanks to his
kindness and sportsmanship that however
was short-lived and to make matters
worse it came with a cost sacrificing
one of Dragon Balls most beloved
characters piccolo episode 34 was
supposed to be the piccolo episode wood
in which piccolo fans would get to see
their big green guy in action in one
episode piccolo marches out to face
Frost piccolo loses Frost is revealed to
have been a lying scumbag the entire
time and cheated to win all his matches
due to this cheating
Goku gets reinstated and you know what
piccolo does bends over and lets Vegeta
take it from here in one episode they
single-handedly ruined what could it be
a potentially interesting character in
frost undervalued and buried a character
many loved and respected in piccolo and
narrative Lee made choices that did not
make sense for any of the characters to
make
I mean beerus decided that Goku was to
go next after Vegeta again why not have
piccolo around he complained about Buu
not getting through the exams why did he
let piccolo go so easy oh yeah
Toei doesn't care about anyone other
than Goku and Vegeta speaking of which
number 7 Tian who this one bothered a
lot of people do you in no small part to
one man in particular mr. plague of
gripes what was a major point to miss
the force of other more pertinent points
plague of gripes made damn sure the
world knew the mean tension on had
become once a respected fighter capable
of standing up to Goku nappa and semi
perfect sell at one point the fall tien
had suffered has been jarring for many
fans to say the least I highly recommend
checking out bigger gripes video which I
will link to in the description if you
want a more in-depth look at tiens
character devourer you really can't even
use that word in Super Canyon he's
barely even a character in his episode
it can be argued he isn't even the
primary focus NGO couldn't even go there
to recruit you he just happened to be
there and was convenient to ask a
character that was once held with the
utmost respect and delivered some of the
most memorable moments in the series has
clearly been forgotten about the outrage
and disappointment amongst fans is
justified I think in this instance
number 6 resurrection F's animation from
here on in the gloves are coming off
every entry from this point on is a
substantial beginning with this those
that join Dragon Ball super late into
its serialization or through the English
dub should count yourselves lucky the
onslaught of truly garbage animation
that hit our screens on a weekly basis
was nothing short of soul-destroying for
any Dragon Ball fan due to scheduling
issues that plagued the series from the
beginning this was by far the height of
their struggle fans around the world
voiced their complaints frustrations and
disappointment regarding Dragon Ball
super just look at it wow that looks
impressive and not at all distracting I
know right this portion of the series is
so bad even the blu-ray releases with
revised artwork still look shabby this
is one instance I don't think anyone
could dispute as being unfair to
criticize when your Dragon Ball is
melting you're done [ __ ] up
number 5 power scaling in a TV show it's
important to have structure and a
coherent narrative continuity if you
lose this suddenly your movie or TV
shows established logic crumbles by the
wayside leaving fans bemused confused
frustrated and cheated introductions to
super saiyan rose' might have been cool
although pushing it a little but it
wasn't until the universe survival ark
that things went from iffy to full-on
ridiculous suddenly without warning or
even decent reasons to back it up
characters who have been ignored
throughout the entire series began to
spontaneously become stronger there's
one instance where Android 17 came out
of literally the middle of nowhere with
the power to rival Super Saiyan blue too
bad he wasn't around to help with beerus
a jutsu tollis poor writing decisions
they had written themselves into a
corner they needed characters to fill
universe sevens team and fill them they
did too bad social media filled up with
infinitely more gripes surrounding their
creative choices number 4 Vegeta's
stolen spotlight this one is
self-explanatory Vegeta is awesome but
never gets anything do you know what
would be nice
if he got something you can promptly
killed on would hand the amount of times
he's achieved
a substantial win and even then I'm
giving you too many fingers to use one
of the biggest problems amongst fans
with the movie battle of gods was that
there wasn't enough Vegeta with the
little screen time he did have for many
he stole the show with the now-famous my
Bulma seen in response to this akira
toriyama when writing the story for
resurrection f ensured that vegeta would
play a more prominent role and to his
credit Toriyama did just that even
though he has very little dialogue in
the entire movie but we'll look past
that training with Goku arriving with
Goku to fight Frieza saving Goku at the
last minute stepping in to exact his
long-awaited revenge on Frieza the man
who had destroyed his home planet it all
looked like it was going to be awesome
but he's about to get his first big win
of the entire series
[Music]
[Applause]
you
naturally justifiably and rightfully
fans in their droves complained and
voice their frustrations around the
scene did we really need another Goku
victory Vegeta later gets to one punch
frost from the tournament but that was
too little too late
number three Future Trunks arc ending
this one who boy this one this is the
one I think that bothered me personally
the most after two dreadful arcs
recanting the movie's plots for 27
episodes when the Future Trunks arc
arrives there was excitement in the air
and with a chemists sense of
everything's going to be alright now the
animation is solid the story is
compelling and the characters are
lovable and fun and then it happened the
ending to the Future Trunks arc is the
biggest [ __ ] you to the fans I have ever
seen and trust me the outrage was felt
throughout the fan base a creator and
editor of Dragon Ball Z and Bridge
Scotty frerichs or Kaiser Necco put it
perfectly the ending of the Goku black
arc is the Rock's fall everyone dies
entry of the franchise episode 66 would
have been a perfectly satisfactory
ending but no tow we had to pull the run
from beneath her feet negating not only
everything good that came from this arc
but also made the entire arc pointless
they lost everything and future trunks
went home literally crying there was no
going back from this
I'd never seen something so pointless in
all of Dragon Ball number 2
Patera retcon and this one actually
happens in the episode prior Wow the
Future Trunks arc as fun as it was it
had so many damn problems figuring out
how to finish its story in Dragon Ball Z
we are told that there are two means of
fusion through fusion dance yielding a
fusion of around 30 minutes a temporary
fusion or photon fusion using the
earrings of the Supreme Kai the fusion
was said to be permanent this added
gravity to the fusion knowing that they
wouldn't be going back to normal once as
effects had taken hold
it was later explained in Dragon Ball Z
that Vegeta infused due to the magic
inside majin buu in Dragon Ball super
they simply say it lasts for one hour if
you're not a Kai this is lazy writing
101 and believe you me the fans let them
know about it it was nice to see VG 2
again but now that the conditions
around the fusion had changed it not
only felt cheap but also made less sense
that Vegeta would be hesitant to fuse
with Goku which he was for some reason
number 1 episode 5 this is it the
motherlode the clip I am so sick of
talking about episode 5 I won't talk
about the animation because let's face
it you all have eyes I would instead
discuss the reaction to said animation
as a fan who grew up watching the series
during its initial run on TV the
announcement of Dragon Ball super was
incredible to me I couldn't believe that
I had the chance to relive those glory
days to join all the characters that I
loved in a brand new adventure once I
got past the initial disappointment of
the first two arcs being essentially
remakes of the movies I was ready to
sink my teeth into this series and
really enjoy it then this happened
inside my head were so many conflicting
emotions I couldn't believe what I had
see I went online and found tons of
articles and people bashing episode
fives visuals it was then at that point
I took a step back from the series and
decided to wait for the English dub to
come out fast-forward to June 2016 and I
make my very first Dragon Ball super
video and to this day for some reason
it's my most viewed video by far no
matter how hard I tried I made that
video to vend my enduring frustrations
at an act that made me believe Dragon
Ball super was going to end before it
even began again the magnitude of this
episode was felt around the globe even
if you weren't an anime fan and chances
are you heard about it in some form or
another despite it not being the worst
the series would get people still make
jokes about episode 5 to this day
despite Dragon Ball super xanimation
being in a pretty good place right now
and so that concludes 10 moments Dragon
Ball super made fans rage do you think I
missed any moments and do you agree with
the ones on my list don't forget to rate
this video if you liked or disliked it
and feel free to subscribe if you want
to see more Dragon Ball anime top 10s at
analysis I try to upload once a week so
feel free to subscribe that'll do it for
this video thank you so much for
watching